This video is sponsored by 1440
tired of bias news stories. 1440 has you covered check out 1440,
the fastest way to an impartial point of view,
the team at 1440 scholars over 100 sources ranging from culture and science to
sports and politics to create a single email that gets you all caught up on the
day's events in five minutes, according to Gallup 51% of Americans,
can't name a news source that reports the news objectives.
1440 has everything you need to be aware of for the day. And most importantly,
it simplifies your life. It's 100% free.
So sign up for 1440 using the link in the description.
And now let's see what grant has.
[Inaudible].
So my friends,
China has become an expert at building cities from scratch cities and many cases
it's true end up empty, or with occupancy rates. Faba loads.
Those initially estimated and the rest of the world,
they are known as China's ghost towns, but Nope,
we are not going to go there in this video because we've already told you about
them several times before. And this video,
we will talk about the rise of one of G Jinping's own personal projects or
project. The Chinese president hopes will become a shining example of the future
development model for the whole country.
A change of paradigm where the government, the state,
and G himself want to play a more leading role in development of the territory
and the local networks that make up the economic and social fabric,
contrary to what has been done so far.
But my friends far from the market criteria that define the evolution of the
so-called special economic zones. As for example,
the well-known cases of Shang gin or the Pudong district in Shanghai,
this new development that we are going to look at today is completely different.
[Inaudible].
I am referring to the new area of [inaudible] a project that is already underway
and the aims to become the mega setting of the 21st century,
a new setting that will occupy three rural counties, rung,
Shang [inaudible] and [inaudible] and Hubei province.
But that's just the beginning.
Although the project estimates and his first phase,
this city will occupy 100 square kilometers.
The intention is that in the medium time,
its size will extend to 2000 kilometers squared to give you an idea that is
almost three times more than the entire area of New York city located near
Beijing, but in a much less developed area.
And one with serious pollution problems,
Jong an aims to become the most technological best connected and most
environmentally sustainable city in China by 2035 with a master plan that takes
into account several phases of development reaching until 2050.
The investment that the Chinese government has committed to this new urban space
is stratospheric. According to Morgan Stanley's estimates,
we are talking about a budget of between 170 and $300 billion of which
approximately half will be used to revive this new metropolis with ultra modern
infrastructure.
The idea is that young and we'll complete the strategic from an economic point
of view.
The city will be located about a hundred kilometers from both Beijing and
champion and important ports and industrial setting. In addition,
it would be connected to the new Beijing airport getting there in just 20
minutes. That'd be only half an hour from Beijing city center.
Thanks to a high speed.
Agree.
These strategic ambitions because of the enormous challenge of represents many
analysts and experts have compared this project to the cases of Shang Gen-X,
which is promoted by president Daniel Jiping in the 1980s and the Pudong
district and Shanghai, which was promoted by Zhang Zimmerman and the 1990s.
I'm sorry to say that Maxine will go.
In fact,
it was precisely the establishment of these two special economic areas that laid
the foundation of modern China,
a China that is open to the market and to the world. However,
my friends GJ Pang's pet project doesn't really resemble either of his
predecessors.
What Zhang is trying to do here is just the opposite to show that a new
socialist China is possible firmly led by the Chinese communist party assessing
where the most important thing is not market oriented economic growth,
but the state itself hold on can a project that does not pooped private
initiative first be successful. What can be learned from past experiences?
I young and be a success or a failure before answering these questions.
We will take a closer look at Shanghai in the late that illuminated the Dawn of
the Asian giant,
the first successful large scale experiment that changed the Chinese model
forever. But before we get started,
you should probably check out our other channel, newly launched visual Academy.
It covers all the most interesting people, places and periods in history.
It's got fantastic animation. It's voiced by a very hands-on sounding guy.
You should check it out by now.
Cracking
the symbol of the dung scalping revolution.
When we are talking about the phenomenal transformation of China and most cases,
we are not really aware of the dizzying speed with which it occurred,
nor what the starting point.
You see.
In the late 1970s, then Chinese leader,
Danielle pink was warned that food production and industry levels were rapidly
declining. It was a risk that scenario,
similar to the great Chinese famine that killed millions of people between 1959
and 1961 would be repeated for this reason, den gel pen,
a leader who had already belonged to the reformist wing of the government in the
Mt era,
decided to try his luck with a new economic system that started at a small and
poor fishing village of barely 30,000 inhabitants. There was a touch.
Oh, you're talking.
Of course about xingjian
There in Guangdong province.
The Chinese government established the first special economic zones in their
history and the first space in mainland China where private investment and
business were allowed in the modern era. In fact,
looking at it from the present,
we can say that this special economic was the first student in the foundation of
the new China to give you an idea that small fishing village of barely three
kilometers squared grew and grew and grew to become a giant with
12 million inhabitants,
2000 square kilometers of surface area on a GDP equivalent to that of all of
Israel or a quarter of that, of all of Spain,
but the historical average annual growth of more than 20% and more than $30,000
of GDP per capita from an economic point of view,
Shenzhen is already at the level of some of the most developed countries in the
world so much so that in the four decades,
since this special economic area was established,
James ends wealth has increased 10,000 fold. Yeah,
you heard that correctly by 10,000 teams in just 40 years.
Amazing, therefore,
but this has been precisely the engine of the new China that we know today and
the place that I've seen the birth of companies as well known as Huawei 10 cent
or ZTE, or that it was out of interest.
The first destination that Zhang Pang visited when he started his job as general
secretary of the party in 2012.
Echoes of dung scalping as CGMP heads to Shen Jen on first inspection
trip, SC.
P in fact, this metropolis is home to some 70,000 technology companies,
which means that roughly 5% of Shankdon's GDP goes to research and development,
however, blind, these crazy figures,
there is more than just a special economic zone.
You see we're location chosen for what was one of the first capitalist zones in
China, right beside Hong Kong and Macau was by no means a coincidence
1979, Hong Kong and Macau were too much richer and more developed territories.
And the rest of mainland China and the differences between Schengen and
neighboring Gonzo were radical precisely because of this,
the choice of the small cities of Shanghai and Shanto and Zhuhai and Guangdong
province of the city of Zaman and Fijian province and the Island province of
high nun for the Chinese government's first capitalist experiment was not a
matter of chance.
One of the keys was to generate symbiosis with Hong Kong and Macau to take
advantage of the experience activity and enormous human and financial capital of
those two enclaves in order to promote the development of the Chinese mainland.
At the same time, if the experiment worked,
it would create an integrated area that would basically facilitate the future
absorption of Macau and Hong Kong,
which at that time were not yet under Chinese sovereignty.
And as we all know today, the plan worked wonders both economically. And
It does my friends,
the shingles development model began to be replicated all over China during the
1980s and 1990s, until we reached the present day,
the G Zhang Pang era G who is considered the most powerful Chinese president
since Moussa dome. And at the same time,
the leader of the economically strongest China in history,
and tends to try his luck with a new model of a special economic area,
a model that has little to do with the one that brought success and development
to China. Do you want to see it? Of course you do.
So now let's take a look at [inaudible] new Chinese.
Dream.
[inaudible].
The own gun seize model for China.
They've already told you the new John and area aims of Rick with the model of
the traditional special economic areas that power the current Chainer GJ ping
wants to spend obscene amounts on his gamble of a new model for the future.
That according to him will guide the next 1000 years of socialism with
Chinese characteristics.
C has a more convinced view of the necessity of a very large direct state
role in the economy than dung ever did. Arthur Kerber, China researcher,
and managing director of Gavi called Dragonomics.
And it's technically a special economic area.
The truth is the market criteria will not be the priority,
nor will the market agents, the companies have the leadership, no,
nothing like that.
There's a special zone piloted and financed entirely by the central government,
a setting by and for.
The state.
In fact, as you can see in this graph,
the Chinese government intends Jong and to be the largest public investment
project and the entire.
History of change,
but it doesn't end there.
This project will not be led by private companies as the state that intends to
pilot the process through a huge investment of public resources,
none of them being orientated to international investment and take note
because not even the real estate activity will fall to private initiative each
and every residential complex to be built in Japan will be promoted by the state
and the property will remain public, which by the way,
has very significant costs.
For example.
Well, the public monopoly on real estate activity will mean that Joan will not
generate the huge revenues from real estate transactions,
like the many billions and foreign investment injected into the development
process of the [inaudible] area and many other economic areas dotted
around the country. And by the way,
as there is no private ownership of land in China,
the farmers currently working in the zone,
an area will be immediately dispossessed with compensation that the state will
decide arbitrarily seasons of farmers will face serious difficulties. No,
exactly. Okay.
Great. Start
by the way.
One of the ironies is the living in Joan and will be closely linked to work.
This may not sound like a bad idea at all,
but there is a problem since the housing is state owned,
it's tied to the job and many believe that losing your job or moving to another
one outside of Yangon will mean losing the right to live and the city as well,
even more control for the one party.
But the big question is if this macro plan has been designed without putting
private initiative first, what are the intend to fund it with?
What does yang Pang intend to be the driving force of what is being hailed as
China's greatest city, perhaps even the future capital of the whole country?
Well, although it may seem strange to you,
the gamble is the Jong-un will be set up to absorb the non administrative
functions of Beijing and its first stage.
And this way the Chinese government wants to move universities,
public companies, hospitals, research centers,
and organizations of all canes there,
everything of course that is state owned or closely controlled by the state.
It is even intended. The private participation could take place,
but only through consortium's that allow private companies to operate,
but where the Chinese government always takes the lead. In other words,
what Zhang Peng proposes is nothing less than to create a Fort a new city that
is not based on trade or competition, but on the public sector.
And he also wants it to be the emblem of the new China.
Along these.
[Inaudible] the development plans and visions of the population of this new
metropolis will grow to more than 7 million inhabitants over the next few
decades,
while at the same time becoming a model of sustainability because the Chinese
president's idea is that, and will also be a green setting.
I trained the Guinea pig on how to build urban models and a new era of low
emission companies, industries, and transports, all of which may sound strange.
And the world's most polluting country in any case,
the first step has to be to close all factories and companies and the area that
doesn't meet the new standards since 2017,
the Chinese government has ordered the closure of more than 5,000 companies and
factories and the region. And the process will continue until the area is.
Is cleaned up.
Let's take one moment here.
Many experts who have thoroughly analyzed the project believed that not only
will it not replicate Schengen success,
but there is a high risk that the city will become a complete.
Feeling.
Can may explain this idea of building a set date based almost exclusively on
several severance and public money on which is far removed from the dynamic of
competition and market innovation. Well, what can I say?
And if we take into account whose hands are controlling the Chinese public
sector, well then the picture is even more bleak.
Having said that the question we should be asking at this point is can a new
city that is oblivious to the demands of the market succeed in 21st century,
China, does it really have something unique, something groundbreaking to offer?
Well, let's take a look.
Story of a predicted failure.
When we speak of failure and Chinese terms,
we did not mean that the city will not be built or that it will not be a step
forward for the region.
Remember that this is an undeveloped rural area and any investment in
infrastructure companies, hospitals, universities,
and other facilities will undoubtedly be an improvement on the original
saturation. However, realistically, it is very,
very likely that the model that Zhang Pang wants to test for China's future here
will simply not work.
The first problem is its location. Unlike Shang Gen-X,
which is next to the financial hub of Hong Kong,
and also has direct access to the sea [inaudible] is inland and an area that is
very cold and winter warm in summer.
And we're living conditions are basically unpleasant.
And although the infrastructure that is already being built is impressive and
promises to connect the new Ceci to Beijing in half an hour.
It is not entirely clear that this will convince people to move there.
At least not in the numbers that Beijing expense. In addition,
let's consider the regulations,
there'll be in place for private activities and the plans for the public sector
to be the one that plays the leading role.
John May well end up becoming a boring set of public workers,
forcibly transferred from Beijing, hardly a massive salient.
[Inaudible].
Jonathan has tough competition and China itself.
What would lead you to establish a business and Jong on if you were also able to
do it, for example, and the young Z Delta.
No.
Apart from the doubts about the success of this setting or the rejection of a
project that seems and practice nothing more than a return to old Soviet
projects of the mid 20th century ones that were designed to consolidate the
power of the communist party elites.
The truth is that the ambition of Zhang Peng and the enormous amounts of money
involved could give rise to a very odd Cain of SETI museum and ultra modern
setting.
It was built overnight and a place where there was little more than rice fields
and very humble peasant houses.
I wouldn't be surprised if it doesn't work half as successfully as China
expects,
but it will be more impressive than anything we've seen in the West for 50
years, shall rune Ling,
urban development expert at the national development and reform.
[Inaudible].
You know, as it may,
we'll have to wait until at least 2035 to see what happens with John,
but my friends for the moment,
the bill dozers and grains have already entered the three counties and the
construction of the main infrastructure is already well underway. For example,
the zone on mega train station,
which was it's 475 square meters on a cost of more than
$1.1 billion will be the central communications hub of Joan.
And this station is expected to open its doors between the end of 2020 and the
beginning of 2021.
[Inaudible].
In any case,
what is clear is that we are no facing a new experiment with a single objective
to consolidate the power of Zhang ping and the political aristocrats of the
Chinese communist party notes that while John was being launched,
Zhang Pang has also announced the creation of new special economic zones. So,
and itself Joan and does not represent a departure from China's economic
development policy, but the experiment is well underway.
I know it's over to you.
Do you think the first great city of the 21st century designed to turn his back
on the private sector can succeed as an isolated project?
Or do you think it will become a point of reference for future projects and
China, and how badly did I pronounce all the Chinese names in this video?
Leave your answers in the comments as always,
we really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos. Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that we're not my dulcet tones. Also,
this channel is possible because of patriarchy and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you next.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.